yes my pleasure introduce lieutenant
Aparri Johnson who is with the st. Louis
Police Department welcome to our show
thank you thank you for having me tell
us what's your position as commander of
the Juvenile Division as hell I'm the
commander Juvenile Division basically I
have 11 detectives and two sergeants and
we handle anything that happens in the
school school bus school property so
basically we're dealing with children
every day and young people and helping
them to rectify some of the situations
that they come across and some of the
things that are dealing with we also put
forth a heavy effort of community
engagement so that we can go out there
we can meet the young people where they
are and get them to see us so who we are
now I got a chance to go to the van
deventer oh yeah juvenile delinquency
division there and meet with some of
those young men and play some chess
thank you i was talking going oh of
course about it ogre some dynamics i
know you started a chess program with
the police department is called chess
cops yes chef cop and tell us a little
bit about that um cops helping enhance
student skills is exactly what it is
eventually what we discovered is that
not every kid play sports and not every
police officer coaches and PAL they
coaches sports so we wanted to find
something that was a little bit
different to give a different group of
kids and a different group of officers
and opportunities to meet to break down
some of those barriers that each of each
each one of them might have you know you
have some officers that may be a little
evident on approaching children because
of some of the things that have taken
place and children same thing with
officers but we figured if we can set
them both down at a table in a strategic
setting and say hey you know what let's
do something that we both enjoy and
let's learn something that we both from
each other that we both enjoy and learn
a little bit about each other then we
can create a good happy environment and
and there can be some serious learning
and some serious dialogue that takes
place and some of the challenges that's
been going on here in st. Louis of
course you know the Ferguson story it's
a beautiful concept how has it been
working at what has been the feedback
after you're seeing the program start
I'm feedbacks been great children get to
see officers for who they are you know
they're a lot of officers out there with
the things that have taken place that
officers are saying hey you know what
I'm not that person you know I'm not
that kind of person and it's up to us to
give them an opportunity to show that
give them opportunity to say hey you
know what this is me and this is who I
em but it also helps young people with
the critical thinking and it helps
officers with their thinking and gets
each entity to see each other just in a
different light so we bring in some good
feedback the kids love it the officers
love it you know we have officers that
don't work for me you know that saying
hey you know what I want to go into the
school and I want to be able to teach
kids because I want them to see me for
who I am and that's something I enjoy
it's fantastic is this program going to
grow you think oh heck yeah we got
glance yes yeah yes yeah yes we got
playing you know there's some things
come up in the summertime and I was just
talking to mark about it we got some
stuff going on in some parts that we
want to do I want to reach out to some
community centers and get some specific
days when when when the community knows
that officers are going to be there to
play chess and you no way you can show
up you don't necessarily be a kid but if
you're a chess player and you want to
meet some of the officers in your
community hey come on which is community
center one day or come on up to this
park this day we're going to have some
officers there we're going to provide
all the chess pieces the tables about
everything and we're gonna play chess if
we can make it happen i'd love to be a
special guest at revenge you're doing
great legal do lieutenant very Johnson
thank you sir chess with cops a
fantastic idea beautiful outreach to the
community great work being done here in
st. Louis